if you add up all of the spots on these
dominoes there are 63 spots so if you
counted all of these dots they're
telling us that would be 63 so we don't
have to do that and then they tell us
that is 42 more spots then the total
number of spots on a six sided die so
they're saying that if you took a
six-sided die so it's excited I might
look something like this to cube it so
might have one dot and then might have
three and then over here it might have
maybe two and so if you count up all of
these dots now the ones we see and then
the ones on the other side as well
there's that's the number of spots on a
six sided die now what they're saying is
is that the 63 spots they said if you
add up all the spots on these dominoes
there are 63 and they're saying that is
42 more spots than the total number of
spots on a six sided die
so let's now figure out how many spots
are on a six sided die so the first
thing you should always ask yourselves
is what they're asking for is this going
to be is this going to be more or less
than the number of spots that you have
on these dominoes and you might say hey
okay I'm reading 42 more I see this word
more it must be 42 more spots you have
to be very very very very careful
whenever you do a word problem don't
just look for words and say oh if it's
more I'll add or if it's fewer I'll
subtract because that's not going to be
the case always you really need to think
about what is the problem asking for
because they're saying this is this 63
dots right over here that is 42 more
than the total number of spots on a six
sided die or another way of thinking
about it is if you took the number of
spots on a six sided die that's what
there that's what they're asking for
so if we say that's question mark so if
you took the number of spots on a six
sided die and you had 42 more than that
and you had 42 more than that then that
is going to be equal to the number of
spots on these dominoes and they tell us
that that is 63 the number of spots on a
six sided die plus 42 is 63 or
sixty three spots is 42 more spots than
the total number of spots on a six sided
die so always think about what they're
saying and so now we could try to figure
out what this question mark is well if
question mark plus 42 is equal to 63
that's the same thing as saying that
question mark is equal to is equal to 63
63 - 42 - 42 so what's that going to be
well we can calculate it so 63 six tens
three ones 42 four tens and two ones we
want to subtract that and when we do
we're going to figure out the number of
spots on the six-sided die so it'll go
to ones place three ones - two ones is
one one six tens - four tens those are
two tens so two tens and one one that's
twenty-one spots twenty-one spots on a
six sided on a six-sided die